let me just begin by noting our
co-sponsor today Columbia's Institute
for the study of Human Rights at our
School of International and public
affairs and I want to thank SEPA
professor Eleazar Barkin who directs the
Institute and David Phillips who leads
its program on peace building and human
rights I also want to recognize and
thank our moderator today NBC News
correspondent and curry a great
broadcast journalist who has managed to
carve out her own unique beat working to
make sure that American viewers are
informed about issues of poverty and
human rights around the world in the
decade since we instituted the world
leaders forum no event has been more
notable or more welcomed than the one we
have today in every era there seems to
be a few individuals who rise within
their countries to stand for a better
life for their fellow citizens and for
lives founded on basic principles like
government by the consent of the
governed and respect for the rights and
dignity of every person and in doing
this and by suffering themselves for
others these unique individuals
transcend their national boundaries and
become emblematic of the strivings of
human beings everywhere dongsaeng tsuchi
is such an individual and we proudly
welcome her to Columbia today throughout
Columbia's long 258 year-old history the
university has studied and stood for
basic human freedoms freedoms of thought
and action
and security good health and meaningful
citizenship this has been represented in
our faculty our students our schools our
institutes and centers and our alumni
our library collections our visitors and
guests and our forums like the historic
one today it is a rich and proud history
but there is just one instance I would
like to draw on this afternoon because
of its relevance to our speaker six
years ago we welcomed into our community
for a long residency another brave
citizen of his country and of the world
who emerged from his own years as a
prisoner of conscience into a position
of national and global leadership the
late President of the Czech Republic but
Slav Havel Havel gave us a remarkable
semester of lectures performances and
opportunities to study his work as both
a playwright and a political leader over
the last decade of his life President
Havel had no greater cause than winning
the freedom of his spiritual cellmate
under house arrest in Burma
dosoo Havel wrote this in The Washington
Post on the occasion of DA Sue's 60th
birthday which he observed in Buddhist
culture marks an important milestone in
one's life he said I would like to meet
her and give her a rose like the one she
is seen holding in the photograph in my
study such an ordinary wish however in
the case of such an extraordinary woman
as Aung San su Chi may seem a silly idea
the current situation is in Burma is bad
he continued but I am still an optimist
seemingly unshakable totalitarian
monoliths are in fact sometimes as
cohesive as proverbial houses of
cards and fall just as quickly
continuing democratization of the whole
region together with growing dissent
inside the country must eventually have
a positive effect as Aung San su Chi
celebrates her 60th birthday I wish for
her that those changes will happen as
soon as possible and that my silly idea
two-hander arroz becomes a simple and
easy thing to do
dosoo Havel understood so well that you
provided hope to oppressed people not
only in your own country but around the
globe demonstrating how to endure both
physical isolation and personal hardship
by keeping one's eyes and heart firmly
and optimistically fixed on what others
may see as an unreachable horizon
sustained by the knowledge the
Democratic Change is not only possible
but inevitable when enough people
finally choose to make it so already on
your historic tour the United States
you've met with President Obama and
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton you
were honored with a gold medal by the US
Congress and of course you have been
justly awarded the Nobel Peace Prize but
let me celebrate the recent progress in
your own in your home country and
welcome you to Colombia by following
hobbles wish and by doing that simple
then now easy thing to do that was
unjustly forbidden to our great mutual
friend welcome to Colombia
so um thank you so much president
Bollinger for some beautiful remarks and
for the presentation that I know was
well received I want to first before we
begin I want to tell you first of all
how lucky as you will know we all are
even beyond what you might imagine
because I understand and you don't know
this yet but the registration for this
event took 34 minutes before it was
closed and that is a first for the
history of this University
so everyone here really wanted to see
you today and the person I would like to
stand to thank for this opportunity
because he helped make today possible he
has worked to support Burma's transition
toward openness he is also the director
of the program on peace building and
Human Rights and it we just heard his
name mentioned by president Bollinger
please Stan David Phillips to be
applauded
so as we are in the company of someone
of a human being who lifts us all and
who for about 15 of 21 years was shut
away so that she would not be heard let
us not waste another second to hear her
opening remarks
ladies and gentlemen Hong sang-soo Chi
thank you thank you for giving me such a
warm welcome I would just like to say a
few words to explain why I want to meet
young people everywhere I go these days
you will have heard of the resources
curse the kind of natural resources that
make it possible for a government and
not to be accountable to its people the
kind of resources cursed with which we
had to put up in Burma because the
military regime could survive for a long
time without support from its people or
even from the rest of the world because
of the natural resources that they were
able to exploit now when people talk
about resources because of course are
thinking of gas and oil and minerals and
so on but we all forget that the most
precious resource of any country its its
human resource and the reason why I'd
like to meet young people and to hear
from them and to exchange views from
them is because we don't want that
resource in our country to turn into a
curse young people who are ill educated
young people who are ill health and
young people who have become who have
lost lost hope because they have no work
these people are a danger to the country
they will create unrest because there
will be simmering resentment against a
world which had produced them and failed
to provide for them and fail to make
them capable of providing for others so
that we might not have this human
resource curse come to our country as a
scourge and to other places in this
world I like to engage with young people
to see what it is that will make them
able to face the challenges of the
future to see how we can help our young
people in Burma who have suffered so
badly from a poor education system that
many of them are unemployed and not fit
to take up any kind of
employment this is why I always appeal
to potential donors to those who wish to
help Burma not only to create jobs but
also to provide our young people with
the kind of training that will enable
them to take up the jobs that have been
created so I was asked only this morning
why young people and this is why because
you are present as well as our future
and you should be our treasure and our
joy rather than our curse and if you
become our curse it's because of us who
have failed to provide you with a
situation in which you could realize
your potential and go on to help others
realize their potential so this is why
I'm here today to hear from you to
exchange views from you and to learn
from you how I can best help the young
people of my country who have not had
the advantages that you have had but who
nevertheless deserve much better than
they have today thank you
so in a few moments we will ask you to
offer your advice to young saeng su Chi
and there are microphones to the right
and to the left of me and in a few
moments I'll ask you to line up there
but before we get the answers you see
from America's youth you said you have
said that in captivity you were not
always thinking of hope you were always
thinking despite all of these years of
what to do next what allowed you to stay
focused on freedom for your people I
think I am a focused sort of person my
approach to life I have once described
as my reaction to
a pressure cooker blowing off I this
happened to me actually in fact I was
cooking and the I was not looking at the
pressure cooker very carefully so do we
still have pressure you would you a few
not really I don't know what kind of
developments they have been over the
last couple of decades I can't keep up
with every one of them and anyway the
pressure cooker exploded because I
wasn't watching it carefully and
everything went all over the room and
for a second I felt panic and then I
thought no let's see what we do next
okay we turn off the gas and then we
have to take a sponge and then we mop up
the mess and so on and so on so I took
it one step at a time and that calmed me
down and that is a lesson I decided that
whenever there's a crisis to be met then
you just do what you can
one step at a time and you'd think
yourself through it this is what I'm
going to do first
then this comes next and after that the
third step is this and so on and then it
becomes very easy and you calm down and
this is how I approached all the crises
of my life during under house arrest I
can't really see that there were too
many crises because there's not much you
can get up to if you're under house
arrest but I did take everything very
calmly in a very practical way step by
step I stuck to a very strict timetable
because that also kept me disciplined
and prevented me from wasting my time at
a house arrest one of the things I did
feel very strongly was all right they've
placed me under under house arrest I'm
not going to give them the satisfaction
of knowing that I've become less
disciplined and that I've dissipated
those years under detention so I tried
to get as much out of those years as I
could get I meditated I read
I listen to the radio exercise I think I
was the healthiest prisoner of
conscience in the world
prisoners of conscience even so often
are influenced by those they whose works
they read or those who they've met who
would you say have been your greatest
sources of influence in keeping yourself
disciplined as you moved ahead towards
your cause first of all my father
because I look for my father not just as
my father but as my political mentor I
had been reading his speeches and his
writings there were not too many that it
is not agreed body of writing because he
was very young when he died he was 32
years in a few months so he had it and
he had led a very very active life and
so they had not been that much time for
him to write long books but he had
written a certain amount all about
politics of course and he had made a
quite a number of speeches which had
been collected together so I had studied
these and they had influenced me they
influenced me a great deal and then
there was also do a howl on arrow
because he had been a personal friend of
my father and the Indian independence
movement had taken place at the same
time as a Burmese independence movement
and there was a very close links between
the leaders of the two countries and
then there was hrvatska father I'm very
glad the president mentioned him because
my during work one of the rare visits
that my family were able to make to me
they brought me his books and so I read
his books I felt very close to him and
he he was so very supportive and I must
take up the story of the rules
because he said that he wanted to give
me a rose about a couple of months ago
when a Czech delegation came to see me
at the new new Capitol in Burma while I
was attending the National Assembly they
brought me a rose that had been placed
on
hrvatska hovels coffin at the time is
funeral and they remembered that he had
wanted to give me a rose and this Rose
was beautifully preserved in in a sort
of perspex case and they did he did
manage to give me a rose so those were
my influences my father Jawaharlal Nehru
and Gandhi Gandhi of course Gandhi's
writings in some ways I have to say I
felt a little bit closer to narrow
because I think our education pattern
was more similar wewe had been educated
in England and we had had the same kind
of intellectual background a Gandhi is
Gandhi is somebody really phenomenal I
think you must all read his works I
think the more you you read Gandhi the
more impressed you are by who he was and
what he was you must remember that
change through nonviolent means was not
ever thought of before Gandhi he was the
one who started it he was the one who
decided that it is possible to bring
about revolutionary change without
violence
we know that Gandhi inspired Martin
Luther King now you inspire so what is
the message above all to those who will
look to you as you have looked to Nehru
and Gandhi and President Havel and your
father what is the message you would
want young people to take away from your
experiences that principals
are not an old-fashioned idea principles
matter you have to build your life on
principles you have to build your life
on a sense of duty these are not
old-fashioned ideas if you build your
life on a sense of duty on principles
you will find you that you're that much
better able to meet the challenges that
life will throw at you it's bounty and
one of the best things about leaving a
principled Duty conscious life is that
you learn to take responsibility for
your own actions and not to keep blaming
others for whatever happens to you now
this is not just in pride in one's
private life one of the big weaknesses
of the previous military regime was that
they blamed others fought for whatever
went wrong in the country we had gained
our independence in 1948 still the
regime was blaming the colonial
administration for the ills of the
country they never once blamed
themselves everything was due to what
the colonial government had done way
back in the past and that contrasted
strongly with what is happening at that
time for example in Vietnam when the
Vietnamese government although a
communist government had been engaging
with the United States and forgetting
the bitterness of the fighting that had
gone on in the country so terribly for
so long at the time when the friend
Vietnam and the United States had
started to engage the Burmese military
regime was still busy blaming the
British colonial government they just
would not take responsibility for their
own actions so Gandhi Martin Luther King
vclav havel they all were people of
principle Vatika fathers living in truth
means
that that you have to be true to your
principles to your beliefs to the cause
in which you believe and in doing so on
your own part one might argue that you
have gone a long way towards what you
wish for your country you have said it
is not done yet
you are still on the way what is the
Burma Myanmar also known as Burma
what is the Burma you envision I have
known a different Burma because when we
became independent in 1948 we became
independent as a parliamentary democracy
and I can always remember that when I
was a child there were many newspapers
which came out every day and we received
or we took in I don't think we actually
took them and they were probably given
to us by by the publishers because they
were friends of my family so there are
always three four or five newspapers
around the house representing different
points of view there was a pro gov
government newspaper there was an
anti-government newspaper in those days
days there were communists insurgencies
and then there were those newspapers
which were leftist although of course
they couldn't support the communist
insurgents as such and I would hear the
adults reading out articles to one
another I was not old enough to read
properly then but I could I would hear
them reading articles in the newspapers
editorial some of which must have been
very witty because they were laughs and
they were to discuss his editorials and
then later when the military regime took
over in 1962 all this change oh I also
have to mention another
a very interesting experience during my
early during the years of my childhood
there were many insurgencies in Burma
including the Korean insurgency and a
friend of our family who was the who was
a Korean minister in the government was
arrested and jailed because he was
accused of having made contacts with the
insurgents of course as he was put into
prison and had lost his job as Minister
his family had to vacate the official
home and they came to stay with us and
nobody thought there's a strange this is
not anything to worry about
we were just having friends to stay and
everybody thought it is the most natural
thing in the world that my mother should
have allowed her friends to come and
stay with us then it seemed perfectly
natural but after the military take over
such a move would have been highly
dangerous taking in the family of a man
who had been put in prison accused of
working against the government and after
the military regime came into power free
newspapers became a thing of the past
and gradually people became more and
more afraid to speak their minds there
was fear everywhere and this contrasted
so strongly from what I remembered of my
childhood that when I think of the
future of Burma it will include some of
the good things we had in the past but
of course you must move on with the
times
one question that many have asked you
already today leading up to this
conversation is what was it was there
one thing more than anything else that
convinced the government the
dictatorship
of Myanmar also known as Burma to agree
to open a little by little to let you
out of that house
well I think I was let out because
elections were over I think it was kept
in I should have been freed in let me
see her to work it out
2009 I think no 2000 in it no I was
freed in ten but I should have been
freed in 2009 but they were planning
elections of 2010 I think most of the
people here may perhaps have heard of
the American who came swimming into my
garden and he and because I wouldn't I
did not hand him over to the police I
did not hand him over to the authorities
as a matter of principle there was no
rule of law in our country and all our
people who were arrested because of the
political activities were denied proper
justice and as a matter of principle I
felt I could not hand over anybody to
into the hands of those who would not
give him the justice that was the do of
every human being so because of that
they brought up a case against me it was
very interesting my detention order says
that I should not write to people
outside now this was in Burmese it's a
little bit difficult to explain but we
don't have we don't say we communicate
with people we say we communicate to or
people communicate from and so my
lawyers and this gentleman had brought a
letter from his young daughter and the
government attorney said that
I had broken the terms of the detention
by accepting this letter and my lawyers
pointed out that it under the detention
order I was not supposed to write to
somebody outside there was nothing about
my receiving a communication from
outsiders but they followed a convoluted
argument whereby to and from bed exactly
the same and therefore I were my
detention was extended instead of been
freezing 2009 I was kept in under 2010
and I think specifically to keep me in
until after the elections which were
meant to place the the party of the army
the u.s. DP firmly at the helm which it
did because that party won over 80% of
the seats but what was it that caused
the government the dictatorship to open
up what more than anything I think it
was the economic mess the country was in
and they felt the need to do something
about it and they began to understand
that they couldn't cope on their own you
have sin because now you're a politician
in light because you're a member of
parliament now and that you would never
say that you would never run for
president of your country can you tell
us how soon that my way actually the
club the president is not elected to
directly its elected by the legislature
okay so depends on how soon the
legislature becomes free and independent
that means changing their constitution
spoken like a politician I'm going to
ask all of you because I don't want to
have doubts which II feel that you did
not get your advice
on how to help young people and also
that you didn't get a chance to hear
your questions which is really why we're
here today there are no stupid questions
but I hope that you will feel free to
step up to these microphones and begin
to line up when you're ready to to ask
some questions but she is here really
not to hear my questions but to hear
yours the first person who reached the
mic is over here to my left please say
your name who you're affiliated with and
please because there are so many
obviously there are a lot of questions
ah song sung GG that that you keep your
questions brief I'm Luke Elm I am a high
school visiting student here and as a 15
year old still in high school how can I
help people in Burma struggle for
democracy should I tell about your
country struggle - my friends should I
write to my two congressmen should I
donate money to organizations to help or
shy help Burmese refugees hear or watch
I do well I do think you really need to
write your Congressman because Congress
is firmly behind the Burmese democracy
movement but all the other three you
could do and that and you would help us
a lot by doing those but I'm very
interested in the fact that you're a
visiting high school student
we have no programs like this in our
country the what I would really like you
to do is to come to visit Burma and find
out for yourself what our schools are
like what our universities are like and
then I think you'll get a better idea of
how you might be able to help us and I
would like you to engage with our young
people this is why I would like you to
come to Burma bring a group of your
friends and get in touch with us and
we'll make arrangements for you to look
around some of the schools you're here -
many of my friends and they'll be very
happy
I spoke to thank you this is your
opportunity your name affiliation please
keep your questions brief mingalaba my
name is Justin I I'm a second year
masters student at Columbia University
School of Social Work
I was born and raised in Burma and I
came here six years ago and my question
is before I ask my question
my goal is my ultimate goal is to work
for the patient first of all I'm sorry
this is the most remarkable moment in my
life this is I'm very excited I cried
already eight so uh my passion is to
work for the people of Burma and I'm
studying international Social Welfare
services to refugees and immigrants I'm
primarily working with Burmese refugees
if there will be any chance to work with
you on issues regarding social work
after my graduation why not there will
be so much to be done I do all I can see
is keep in touch and what we will do -
at the end of the program is to give you
the email of the NLD headquarters and
you can keep in touch with us through
that address and thank you very much for
thinking of going back and helping our
people and good luck with the studies
thank you very much
hello my name is Siva I am a junior in
Columbia College so my question is a few
days ago you indicated that your visit
to the United States should not be in
any way seeing as a hostile step toward
China so my question is if the NLD were
to become the ruling party in Burma what
changes if any would you make in sino
Burmese relations we used to have very
good relations with China now the
difference now is that all of the
relations between the governments remain
good people-to-people relations are not
as good as it used to be this has more
to do with Chinese businesses in Burma
than with the government-to-government
relationship many people in our country
feel that Chinese businessman in Burma
do not care for our country and our
people that they're only there for the
sake of their own profits so I would
like to change this I would want I would
like better people-to-people relations
we would like our people to get to know
one another not just as businessmen and
their clients but as se students to
students housewives to housewives people
to people that is what I would like to
see the re-establishment of friendly
relations between the peoples between
the governments we've always had a
policy of good relations with our
neighbors thank you very much yes please
feel free my name is dana waters I'm a
first year student at the Columbia
School of International and public
affairs and if I stumble over words I'm
sorry I don't get a lot of chances to
speak to Nobel Prize winners for the
past eight years I've been working in
various
stays with Amnesty International and a
year ago we rallied outside the embassy
in Washington DC and delivered a few
hundred letters and it's incredible to
see you here today
I'm just as a suggestion I suppose that
sort of activism has for me been a way
of channeling all of the anger and
discontent that I've felt
whether in my own life with my
government and I can only hope that that
would be something helpful to young
people in Burma but I was wondering from
your perspective as somebody who has
been on the posters of so many
organizations and is someone who we
learn about when we first start what is
your perspective on these groups and the
effect that they have I think what you
said is very good you must use your
anger in a positive way by helping
others I've always said that people who
under spare would help themselves best
by trying to help others and it's I mean
it's marvelous that you know that there
is in anger and discontent inside you
and that you've got to try to put this
to good use and by the way let me say
that you needn't apologize about
stumbling I tend to do that too and one
of the results of long years and the
isolation is that in a way I forgot how
to speak fluently and even now when I'm
tired I cannot get my words and
sentences together this is a result of
long years of not having conversations
with other people so please don't
apologize by the stumbling and thank you
for what you did for Burma it did matter
I never received a single letter that
the members of analysts the
international sent me these letters were
not allowed to get through to me but I
knew that they had been written and I
appreciated it
my name is David Abrahamson I'm a second
year student at the School of
International Public Affairs my wife and
I had the pleasure of visiting your
country in February of 2011 as part of
our honeymoon and we had a delightful
time we even drove by her house
unfortunately we were there but so it's
an honor to see you in person now myself
and a lot of my classmates are really
interested in working in international
nonprofits after our studies what do you
think are one or two areas that
international nonprofits can make the
biggest contribution to Burma and
Burma's people anything to do with law
myself a little bit over France because
of course there are lots and lots of
nonprofit organizations but as the
chairman of the committee for the rule
of law and tranquillity and both much
needed in Burma I would very much like
help with improving the ability of our
young lawyers the study of law like
other branches of of of academic life in
Burma suffered during the years under
the military regime and we need good
lawyers we need all kinds of educated
people for example I need a speechwriter
I think if our young people have been
better educated I wouldn't have to write
to all my speeches I could just get one
of them to write them for me so we need
so much help to bring our young people
up to the standard of that that has been
achieved in other countries so again I
would say please get together with your
friends and put together a suggestion as
to what kind of help
you would like to give and please
contact the NLD okay thank you very much
thank you that's who there are many good
writers in this room
ah advertise for speechwriter but you
won't get a salary
mingi ah
Mahalo my name is wayyy kine I'm a first
year graduate student in the mailman
School of Public Health focusing on
health policy in the global context and
you know my passion like Java is also to
return to remember one day and you know
possibly do a positive impact now in
your opening statement you open the
floor up and asked us for advice or
suggestions and well one of my
professors here at convey is that the
best way to answer a question is with a
question so my question is what do you
see the role of students who are
studying abroad you know be it the
United States being the UK and even in
Southeast Asia in terms of one we
reenter the country can we do so in a
tactful manner so that we're in a
position to actually make these type of
impacts and I also have a follow-up
question is what do you see as the role
of academic institutions such as
Colombia other academic institutions in
helping Burma develop and grow young
people who have been educated abroad
have much to offer Burma but they have
to know how to do it and they have to
find out where they can be of best use
some who have been educated away from
Burma have grown away from not just from
the country itself but from the way in
which our people react and from the way
in which our people think now of course
it's also the question of language if
you still speak Burmese well that's no
problem but a lot of young people who
have been educated abroad well I'll have
to put this quite frankly choose not to
speak Burmese well and that I've never
liked I do not think that you should
take pride in forgetting your native
language you can take pride in mastering
a foreign language but that does not
mean that you have to forget your own
line
so if you really want to come back and
help Burma you must do it with a sense
of humility grateful for the opportunity
to serve grateful that you are able to
give what others cannot give I think
that's a great necessity because the
Burmese are a proud people the fact that
they're poor the fact that they are
uneducated does not mean that they like
been treated as poor uneducated people
so you did mention the word tact I think
you'll need a lot of it and academic
institutions we we are in the process of
drawing up a university education law in
the legislature and when that law has
been drafted and adopted we hope that it
will make our universities more open
more progressive and then there will be
more in need of contacts with
universities abroad that they might be
able to raise their standard of teaching
as quickly as possible in the meantime
of course you could always offer
scholarships to some of our best
students in Burma but I would like to
make a point that we have very good
students who are who are intelligent and
who hard-working but who do not know
enough English whose English is very
poor and I would like to appeal to
universities who are thinking of
offering scholarships to our young
people to consider giving them an
intensive language course for say three
four months before bringing them in into
an undergraduate program the sort of
thing is done in countries like Japan
for example they have taken given
scholarship so Yankee from people from
Burma they put them in a language school
for several months and after that these
students are ready to
in the regular program of the
universities didn't I do my yeah buddy
good afternoon son honor to speak with
you
I'm Julian Hector engineering class of
2010 no my first experience with Burma
was with a former former classmate in
high school about ten years ago and her
father was a doctor who had left Burma
because of the situation near the
politics and the economic situation and
I've met I met many more Burmese since
then in college one was a roommate of
mine and beyond just the politics one of
their biggest frustrations was with the
economics in the country you know
obviously the sanctions have contributed
to that but they often felt powerless to
to help in any way what specifically
would you recommend to students to
people in the Burmese diaspora as far as
helping to helping your your country to
grow economically but the people in the
Burmese diaspora first they must decide
for themselves whether they want to go
back to Burma or not you can help Burma
even if you don't go back there there
are other ways of helping for example
you can help students who've come abroad
to study
you can help refugees you can help by
donating to organizations helping with
humanitarian work there are many ways
you can help you don't have to go back
to the country but if you decide to go
back to the country then as I was saving
earlier you've got to to make up your
mind as to where and how you want to
help so first of all if you are settled
here I would like to say to lose but
means who have settled here you don't
have to be ashamed of it you don't have
to feel guilty about it you can help if
you want to and I always say even if you
do not want to help Burma as long as you
are a good citizen of this country I'm
satisfied because at least you would be
a credit to a country we can say that
this marvelous person comes from Burma
and even if he or she is not able on or
not for some reason or the other willing
to engage again with Burma I will be
satisfied people have the right to
choose their own lives and they must not
live with the feeling that they are
obliged to help but of course if they
would help I'd be very happy thank you
noon um my name is Suarez Saleh I am a
junior at Columbia College a few days
ago in an interview with Christiane
Amanpour you said you have a soft spot
for the military generals I'm wondering
if you could explain that comment and
explain the insurmountable moral courage
you had to say that and if you could
give us advice as students and how to
deal with people on the opposing side
well I'm in a very unusual position
because my father was the founder of the
Burmese army and my first memories of my
father are of him in uniform in the
photographs I don't remember him because
I was only two when he died but most of
the photograph photograph so we had of
him around the house showed him in
uniform and of course I was brought up
to understand that he was the father of
the Burmese army and the soldiers of the
army used to refer to him as their
father and in fact when I was growing up
ordinary soldiers complete strangers
would address my mother as mother so I
grew up with the feeling that I was part
of the army family and of course they
were also my father's old soldiers who
were always coming and going because of
that I could never really hate the the
generals although I hated what they were
doing and because of my father I do have
a soft spot for men in Burmese military
uniform
but learning is learning not to hate
I was speaking just this morning to some
of Burmese Americans and I made the
point that hate and fear are linked
together and when you hate somebody you
must really ask yourself why and you
will find that it is because you fear
that he may hurt you in some way he or
she I do not think you can actually hate
anybody unless you have this fear the
fear that he or she will be able to hurt
you may be able to hurt you in some way
so if you want to get over your hate you
must get over your fear first thank you
so much and how do you get over your
fear how do I get him yeah well I'll
tell you a practical way I got over my
fear of the dark when I was small I was
very afraid of the dark I was terrible
whenever we went into a room at night I
somebody had to go in front of me and I
would bury my face in that person's back
and say put on the light put on the
light put on the light and until the
light had been switched on I wouldn't
open my eyes I was that afraid of the
dark I was afraid of ghosts and I
thought that ghost lurked in the dark
and my mother was very disapproving
because she was a brave woman and she
didn't like the fact that I was so I was
so cowardly and I got tired of it I got
tired of this fear I got tired of the
fact that I was frightened every time I
went into a dark room so one day when I
was about 11 I suppose I thought this is
about enough no I was I had to stop this
and I found a very simple way of doing
it our house is a two-story house and my
mother used to make us drink a hot cup
of milk every night a nightcap and this
would be made for us in the
would have it and then we go upstairs
and everybody would go upstairs so I
would say to my mother this Merc is too
hot I can't drink it yet
and I would leave it downstairs and then
we would all go upstairs and after
everybody was upstairs and downstairs
was in complete darkness I would say I'm
going down for my milk and I would come
down and and of course I would have to
find my way to the dining room and there
through the dark rooms but the light on
and half my milk all alone in this dark
downstairs
and then switch off the light and find
my way back up again it was terrible for
just about 10 days and after that
finished so you have to face your fears
that's the only way you get rid of them
my name is hunter McDonald I'm a first
year student at Columbia Business School
and in fact when I was 11 years old I
had dinner in Scotland with your husband
Michael Aris and he spoke so fondly of
you and with such great hope and it's
just incredible to see you here now in
New York can have it come full circle
but um as a business school student I
have a business-related questions and my
perhaps uninformed perspective of Burma
at this point is that due to its
isolation its level of economic
development and business involvement is
sort of a blank canvas and he spoke of a
potential for a human resource curse and
I'm interested in hearing your
perspective on moving forward how you'd
like to envision an economy in Burma
that both involves its young people
without alienating the business
incumbents and where you see that
evolving moving forward well I'm
starting by encouraging what I call
democracy and human rights friendly
investment we would like the kind of
businesses which care about the
environment which care about the their
and their laborers their workers
which which engaged in outreach programs
and also I am very interested in what I
call 20th 21st century agriculture
business because food security is going
to be a greater and greater concern and
I want our aggregate of course is in
ruins in Burma including their
agricultural sector which gives us a
chance to bring a bill build everything
up from scratch so if you're in business
I would like you to see how best we
might develop our agricultural sector so
it's in line with the future rather than
the past don't forget that the 20th
century is now the past and yet a lot of
businesses operating now are still 20th
century star and yet we are one decade
well into the second decade of the 21st
century so that's how you can help us
think how we can make agriculture a 21st
century business keeping in mind that
there will be a growing need for more
and more food in this world thank you
darling I'm Thea Merlyn applause I'm
currently a first year PhD student in
political science but if you're still
accepting speech writing applications
that might change it appears to me that
Burma's transition to democracy has been
relatively peaceful compared to the
chaos and violence that greets such
transitions today in other parts of the
world most prominently Syria what role
does violent resistance play in
transitions toward democracy and can it
ever be a legitimate means to a
democratic end well I think it should
always be the means to a democratic end
because I believe that means cannot be
divorced from ends if the means are not
right
then you will distort the end itself a
very goal that you set out to achieve
will become distorted if you use means
that are contrary to the principles on
which you should base that goal the you
said that Burma's transition to
democracy has been relatively peaceful I
don't think we can put it quite like
that because don't forget that the
transition began in 1988 not in 2010
because we fell under military
dictatorship in 1962 and 1988 was a
great uprising against what they then
called one-party rule which was
dominated by the military or ex members
of the military so that was put down
very violently and then of course there
was the 2007 saffron revolution when the
monks led a nonviolent LED nonviolent
demonstrations and were also put down
brutally so we can't really say that the
transition to Burmese demcrata to
democracy in Burma has been free of
violence but certainly my party the
National League for Democracy always
held to the principle of non-violence
this is not always the case with all the
other forces for democracy we were the
ones who started out by saying we have
to use nonviolent means and we kept to
that or in spite of the tremendous
oppression we suffered so I think not
only does non-violence work it can be
made to work and it should be the only
way to democracy if you want that
democracy to be the kind that is not
warped by the root of violence thank you
so we are beginning to see the clock is
ticking and there are so many who want
to ask questions so let's see if we can
ask very brief questions and see if we
have some brief answers can see how many
we can get through my name is Kate Amara
I'm second
second-year student the school of
international public affairs I'm a girl
up in Japan and I'm happy that you
mentioned the research you work in Kyoto
University that I'm graduate from and my
question sorry I was working for United
Nations office of disarmament Affairs in
Asia and I through my research about the
insurgency groups of Burma I always felt
that there were so many insurgency
groups and my question is how will you
work for the security and the
unification of Burma because there are
so many different groups of different
opinions at the moment of course they
are peace talks going on between the
government and various ethnic groups
this will take time but there are always
two sides to demands of minority groups
it's one is to do with development and
humanitarian issues and the other is to
do with the identity and we've got to
address both issues if we are to resolve
the problem the long run thank you good
afternoon
dawn Tsuzuki I'm Jean Cho a first year
student of Columbia College I come from
a very large country near Burma China
and first of all I would like to say
thank you because back to your previous
comments you say that this sort of not
so good relationship between China and
Burma is not only caused by some
government issues but also some
individual businessman in Burma which
inspired me to go to Burma in the neste
sommer holiday and then comes my
question several months ago I was
watching a movie about you the lady and
there's a scene which impressed me a lot
there's a lot of young people in the
movie they're helping you to launch the
political campaign but at the same time
a lot of them were caught by the
government and they were brutally killed
by the government I was so terrified and
delusion because they're so passionate
but they're so powerless in phase of the
dictatorship so my question is that what
do you think is the best time for the
young people to participate in politics
whether
they're very young or reckless or when
they are very mature but sometimes
conservative especially for those come
from the country with certain extent of
dictatorship thank you when they're
young and restless you can't keep them
out of politics anyway they do it if
they want to but I think people grow to
be mature adults and in my country they
in my party there are many who came to
us in the early 20s and who are still
with us now in their 40s now as mature
members of the party because they've
remained true to our cause if you
believe in the cause for which you are
working no age is the wrong age every
age is right some of our party members
started out in the 70s so every age is
right if you're dedicated hi my name my
name is Tim I'm a junior in Columbia
College I was also born and raised in
China so a lot of what you said struck
me because um those things to do is to
apply to China today such as the lack of
freeze trust and barely functional legal
system and that is one of my dream I
guess it's my dream to change that
however the Chinese system is highly
complicated sophisticated in terms of
deterring activists and this dissidents
and I'm wondering whether you think
democracy is the ultimate solution to
situations like China and what can
students like me do because by virtually
being here I'm blocked from a lot of the
ways to bring up substantial changes
within a system it is for the people to
decide what system they want and in
Burma the people did choose democracy in
1988 that people were demonstrating for
multiparty democracy because we had been
under one-party dictatorship for so long
so in the end it's a people who decide I
decided to work for the cause for
democracy because I believed in it as I
said earlier I grew up in a democratic
Burma and by the time dictatorship came
to Burma I was in other democratic
countries in India first and in England
in the States and so on
I believed in democracy you can only
achieve something that you really
believe in so your people must decide I
believe in democracy but I cannot say to
other people this is what you must
believe and this is what you must go for
it is for you to decide what would best
suit your country and you as an
individual has the right to think what
might be the right answer thank you you
can only achieve what you really believe
in that's a that's a terrific thing to
remember I'm so sorry to say that we are
out of time for questions but let me do
this what is the email address where
people might apply their job as a
speechwriter well you can give it to me
and I can read it out loud by the way I
think I must say that Seattle who is
what our youngest MP is also a
hip-hopper an ex-prisoner of conscience
too bad we don't have much time although
otherwise I could have made him sing for
you while they're looking for the email
address let me also just simply say that
behind every great woman such as on song
Sochi there is a fantastic team and if
it would be acceptable to you might you
all stand the team of Aung San su Chi
please stand and be recognized for your
support and money tog
could I said just a few words about them
as this is I I keep calling him bunny
and I can never remember his real name
anyway bunny who is standing this side
came to me in 1988 as a young student of
about 18 or 19 and here he is still with
us and the Alpha in the middle is our
youngest MP as I said earlier he is a
hip-hopper he was a prisoner of
conscience for several years and
released just before I was released and
at the end is doctor tomorrow my
personal assistant now she is unique
because he was working for UNICEF for
many years and getting an excellent
salary and I said to her last year you'd
better leave your job I can't pay you
anything but you better come to work for
me as you did
so since most of you here are students I
hope that you have a piece of paper and
so that someone and if you don't then
you can and a pen if someone is with you
maybe they can share this the email
address is I n fo not n LD bu r ma at
gmail.com I'm going to repeat it i NF o
dot n LD burma at gmail.com thank you
for your wonderful questions this has
been a really wonderful audience I'm so
sorry we can't get to any more questions
but I don't want you'd like to write
down your questions and send them to a
to that email address if you email your
questions to this address you'll answer
you let me just however take just two
more minutes which is all we have left
to allow dal-su to make some closing
remarks about her thoughts I hope your
answers you've gotten some answers from
these students yes and I'm very happy
that there are so many of you who want
to ask questions because if you have
lived under a dictatorship for a long
time you forget how to ask questions you
just do everything that your tool to do
and the fact that so many of you are
coming up wanting to ask questions means
that you do not live under a
dictatorship I'm very glad you find that
out and please do email your questions
to me I will not be able to send replies
to them immediately because this email
of course is that of our office in Burma
I'll be in the States until the 4th and
then I go back to Burma and I would not
be able to pick up your quests questions
immediately there probably other things
I have to do first but you will get
answers to them make sure that you say
that your you were one of those at
Columbia University on the 23rd of
September thank you I think maybe an
email from
sang-soo Qi might be worth not having
had an opportunity answer your question
here today thank you
now on song su Qi
ladies and gentlemen please remain in
your seats as we export the speakers out
of the building first thank you
you